turning now to the pandemic president
biden says americans with
long covet can now qualify for federal
disability resources
and can have access to federal
disability protections
the president's announcement highlights
new joint guidance from the departments
of justice and
health and human services it clarifies
that long covet can be a disability
under federal anti-discrimination laws
our consumer investigative correspondent
that's anna warner has been covering
long covet and disability issues for
some time
anna good morning to you so how will
this help the covet long haulers
at right now well good morning gail and
as you know we've heard from many of
these
long coveted patients who have said
they've had trouble
getting recognition from employers from
insurance companies
saying yes you do have a disability
a lot of the problem here is that the
symptoms are so vague
well basically experts we spoke to said
this is the biden administration saying
yes we're officially putting everybody
on notice
long covid can be a disability that's
addressed to state and local governments
to employers to insurance companies
another thing that this guidance spells
out
is some of the symptoms brain fog
fatigue it gives everybody a sense yes
this
it can be a real disability now does
that mean that
everybody is automatically covered not
necessarily
these patients still have to be
evaluated by their doctors
they still have to qualify they have to
have the right symptomatology
but this is a way to put everybody on
notice yes these people have access to
federal resources
and yes this can be a disability an
important move anthony
all right it sure is anna thank you